understanding css flexbox is important
if you want to make
responsive websites james maxwell
created this course
along with some amazing pdf cheat sheets
to go along with it
flexbox is going to change your
perspective about web designing and
again for the part of our course i have
created two beautiful pdf cheat sheets
which you can download these cheat
sheets have got
every single property that we are about
to learn now
one is exclusive for the parent
container properties
and the other is exclusive for the child
properties
you can use these cheat sheets for your
future reference i highly encourage
everyone to follow the video now
and then later use the cheat sheets so
let's dive into the concept of flexbox
without any further delay
we're going to create a separate file
for this learning purpose so that you
can refer the file along with the cheat
sheets in the future
let's quickly set up a html file using
the emit function
now i'm going to teach you guys another
emit function to create
a container and the children inside it
so
we need a div tag with a class container
and then insert a greater than symbol to
create a few children
inside the container let's give the
child elements a class called items
so again we'll have to insert a dart and
just type items
and we also want every child element to
have a unique number to it
so insert a hyphen then insert
a dollar symbol times five
this emit function will create a
container with five items numbered
within
it we also want the items to have one
unified alias name to them
and we're gonna call it as item
so again insert a dot and just type item
now hit enter how simple was that
this might look a little intimidating at
the beginning
but once you get used to it out of
practice you won't be able to create
hatchimal containers without these
beautiful emit functions
to learn more about these emit functions
you can visit docs.mi.io
now before moving to our css file we'll
have to fill in the numbers
inside a div tag
let's quickly create a css file and link
it with a html file
let's begin with the basic resets using
the universal selector
so we're going to set the margin to zero
to zero and
box sizing to border box
next we're going to style a container in
the child elements to implement the
flexbox properties
so we're going to target the container
now
and give it a background color
of hash c a c a and c a
which is a light gray color and then
give it a padding of 10 pixels
then a margin of
50 pixels next we're going to target the
item selector
and i'm going to give them a background
color
of hash ff0037
which is a nice red color and then
for the font into the item we're going
to give them a white color
font size of 35 pixels
a padding of 20 pixels
and a margin of 10 pixels
if you see here we haven't implemented
any flex box yet
but we have a gray color container and
red color items inside the container
the items could be anything on a real
website it could be the nav bar of the
website
are few images paragraphs or
whatever this video is all about the
flexbox container properties
to enable flexbox we'll have to set the
display property to flex
inside the container so let's set the
display property to flex
inside a container
you can already see the magic flexbox
has produced a work a lot
as you can see to create this kind of
layout using the float property
position property and the margin
properties it would have been a tedious
process
i would never take that risk personally
just by setting the display property to
flex in the parent container
the child elements have become the flex
items
now let's talk about the flex direction
property
the flex direction property is used to
define the direction of the flex items
within the container
by default the flex direction is set to
row
when the flex direction is set to row
you see nothing happens
apart from row there are few other
direction values
that will change the direction of the
children into the container
let's see them one by one when we change
the flex direction to column
you can see the children items are
arranged vertically in a column
that's the superpower flexbox by setting
the direction to column
we have changed the axis itself there
are two different axes according to
flexbox
the main axis and the cross axis the
axis differs for different directions
for the flex direction set to row the
main axis would be the x-axis
for the flex direction set a column the
main axis
would be the y-axis this concept is
nothing related to the flexbox
or web development this basic math
to invert the direction of the flex
items in either column
or row we can use the column reverse or
the row reverse values
when the direction is set at column
reverse
you can see the direction of the items
are inverted in the y-axis
so the main axis here goes from the
bottom to top
where before it was going from the top
to bottom
and of course the numbers are in the
reverse order
phi is in the top and one is in the
bottom
the same rule applies for row reverse
you can picturize what that one would do
so when i set the flex direction to row
reverse
exactly it stacks the items in the
reverse order
here the main axis moves from right to
left
and the numbers are also in the reverse
order
you should always be aware of the main
axis that's really important
since we have experimented all the
possible values
for flex direction property let's set it
back to row
which is the default value
we haven't explored much about flexbox
yet but
i'm sure you could understand how much
flexbox is going to help us
in the making of a responsive design
probably when designing for a smaller
screen
we can simply set the flex direction to
column which will stack the items
one on top of the other so that's all
about the flex direction
next up i want to discuss about the
justify content property
so remember that the justify content
property defines how the flex items
should be stacked along the main axis
let's start with the center value here
now automatically all the flex items are
stacked in the center here
let me zoom in a little bit so you can
see things clearly
right you can always use the dev tools
to inspect the elements
the browser had understood that this div
tag
is using flexbox when you hover over the
justify content property
you can see how beautifully flexbox had
calculated the distances
and align the items in the center
just imagine if we didn't have flexbox
to create this very simple layout
well we should have used the float
property that would have been
a real nightmare for us so the center
value aligns the flex items
right in the center of the container but
it does not do anything with the space
in between the items
the space between the items is because
of the margin value we gave
for item selector so if we come in this
value
you can see a flex items are tightly
packed
let's quickly uncover this margin and
experiment the next value
which is space between so let's change
the justified content
to space between
when we set the justify content to space
between
you can see that the space between our
flex items are evenly distributed
we don't have to specify any number here
but flexbox
automatically calculates the distance
and distribute the items according to
the space available
the best part here is when we adjust the
size of a browser
the space between our items also adjust
so that makes it really handy to create
a responsive layout
let's now comment the margin property
inside the item selector again
because we're going to explore another
value which is similar to the space
between call
the space around changing the justified
content
to space around
you can see the space run value had
created equal amount of space
on both the left and the right side of
the flex items
the space between these two items is
twice the amount of space
on the left side of this item
next up we're going to see the space
evenly value
so changing the justified counter space
evenly
when i started using the flexbox i
initially didn't understand the
difference between these values
that's totally normal you'll start
understanding these values
once you start using them in your
projects
so setting the value to space evenly
you can see that the space between the
flex items is
evenly distributed on both the sides
the space between flex item 1 and flex
item 2
is the same as the rest so
while space evenly ensures that the
space between the items
is always the same on both the sides the
space around
make sure that the space around each
item is the same on the left and the
right side
definitely not a big difference but the
usages differ completely
there are two more values for the
justify content property
the flex start and the flex end values
and the justify content is set to flex
start
well it is the default value let's
uncomment the margin value
to ensure that
yes it is the default value
now if we set the justify content to
flex n
here i want to complete attention people
often confuse between row reverse and
the flex in values
row reverse will invert the order of the
flex items
but the flex in value only moves the
flex items to the end of the container
maintaining the margin if provided
all right the last property we are going
to discuss in this video
is the align items
the justify content property aligns the
flex items along the main axis
but the align items property aligns or
flex items along the cross axis
in order to make the align items
property work we're now going to make
one of the flex items bigger than the
rest because
a reflex item is having an unified
height
so it will be difficult to demonstrate
the align items property
we're going to pick the third item
and set its height to 150 pixels
let's also change the justification to
center
and here it is
i'm just noticing an error with my
nomenclature
i have included numbers for items which
should have been for item
that's totally fine here you can see
that
all of flex items are now having a
height of 150 pixels
and not just the flex item 3. that's not
a bug
but it happens because the default value
for
align items is stretch when the align
item is set to stretch
this is what happens so
let's now set the align items to center
all right we can visualize how align
items property align our flex items
along the cross axis here we have one
flex item that is bigger than the rest
and with the align items property set of
center
we center the smaller flex items
relative to the bigger one
in the vertical fashion if we now set
the align items to flex start
all the items will stack to the top
along the top of the bigger flex
item the opposite will happen if we set
the align items
to flex end
so the flex items are aligned equally at
the bottom
so far we saw center flex start flex in
and the stretch values for the align
items property
the stretch value tries to stretch the
height of all the flex items
to match the height of the tallest flex
item
there is one last value for the align
items property
it is called the baseline to utilize the
baseline value
we'll first have to increase the font
size of one of the item
so let's select item number four
and increase its font size
to 70 pixels
if you now set the align items to
baseline
you can see that it aligns all the flex
items
along the text inside the item number
four on an imaginary line
i'm now going to reset align items to
center
and get rid of items number four
and items number three selectors here
all right we're coming to the end of
this video
so flex direction justify content
and the align items are the most
important
and the frequently used properties of
course there are few other properties
but we'll see them in another video
before we end this video i want to
answer to one of the highest rated
question
what will happen to justify content and
the align items property
when the flex direction is set a column
well
let's check that out
great if you notice the main axis had
changed now
it is no longer going from left to right
but it is going from top to bottom
everything is fine but why is that the
items are aligned to the center yet
well that's due to align items is set to
center
and the flex direction is set a column
when the flex direction is set a column
the main axis would be the y
axis and the cross axis would be the x
axis
we know that the align items property
affects the cross
axis and that's why our items are
aligned at the center
vertically so if you now set the align
items to flex
end
and you can see that the items are
aligned at the end of the container
vertically the opposite of this will
happen if we set the align items to flex
start
and yes the items are stacked at the
beginning of the container
so i would again emphasize you guys to
always keep a track of the main axis
and the cross axis in order to use
justify content and the align items in
the right way
now for your better understanding i'll
also experiment with the justify content
when the flex direction is set up column
for that
we should first set a height value for
the container so
maybe let's set it to 1400 pixels
and then i'll decrease the size of my
viewport
now let's add justify content to space
between here
if i hover over the justify content on
my dev tools
you can see that the space between the
items are distributed just as we saw
earlier
but in the vertical direction all right
let's end this video here i know i'm
leaving most of you with a skeptical
mind
but that's totally normal for any
beginner i felt the same
when i learned flexbox for the first
time and that's why i made those
beautiful cheat sheets
for the reference purpose i feel it
would have been better
if someone gave me those cheat sheets
when i started learning flexbox
you can now re-watch this video along
with the cheat sheet so that you get a
better clarity about these concepts
let's quickly set the flex direction to
row remove the height
and set justify continuing align items
to center
and end this video
great let's meet back in the next
lecture to learn more about the flexbox
concepts
in the last lecture we learned three
important flexbox container properties
there are a few more but we'll see them
later
now in this video let's learn about the
flexbox child properties
so this is where we left in our last
video
the first property we're going to learn
in this lecture is the align self
property
the aligns of property is similar to the
align items property
with the help of align items property we
were able to collectively change the
alignment of a flex items
along the cross axis but the align self
property
will align one single flex item along
the cross axis
and it can also override the align items
property
i know it sounded like gobbledygook
let's see them in action to understand
how it works
to experiment the align solve property
let's again create the item 3 selector
and give it a higher of 150 pixels
we're going to use item 3 as a reference
point
so let's try applying align self to item
number 4.
right after item number 3 we're going to
create item number 4 selector
and creating a lens of property here
let's set this to flex start
well you can see that only item number 4
is aligned at the start of the flex
container and
all of the flex items are aligned to the
center of item 3
along the cross axis align self property
accepts every single value that align
items property accepts
but as i told you earlier we use align
solve property
only to align an individual item
now let's change this to flex n and see
what happens
so the item had moved to the bottom of
the flex container now
when airlines alpha set a stretch
well the item stretches to match the
height of the tallest item
which is item 3 in our case
now i'll leave this to you guys go ahead
and experiment the other possible
values like center space between space
evenly
space around and try to analyze the use
cases
next up we're going to play with the
order of flex items
the order property is used to change the
portion of flex items
within the container to experiment this
property
we're going to create selectors for all
of flex items and
change the order
the initial value of order zero so
according to flexbox the flex item one
is in the zeroth portion let's set order
property to every flex
item and change the portions
so we're gonna move item one to portion
three
then item 2 to portion 4
item 3 to portion 0
item 4 to position one
item five to portion
two so
after saving the file you can see our
items are relocated
i want you guys to understand that these
values i give here
are just experimental values you can go
ahead
and arrange the items as you wish but
again
i would encourage everyone to follow the
order i'm giving here
so that we can stay on the same track if
you see here
one is a third person two is at fourth
position
three is at zeroth position four is at
first position
and five is at second portion
the order property will be handy for us
to relocate the position
of the elements when it comes to
responsive design
you can see some people using negative
values to change the order
but i never encourage anyone to use
negative values
that will confuse us when we look at our
code in the future
that's all about the order property
we're now going to see
the last three properties associated
with the flexbox child
items the flex grow flex
ring and the flex bases
i'd remove the order properties from all
of flex items
we're first going to see the flex grow
property now
the flex curve property enables a flex
item to grow
to grow a flex item all we do is specify
an integer
just a number like how we assign to the
order property
to experiment this property let's apply
generally in the item selector
so i'm going to create a flex screw
property
and set it to 1. wow
all our flex items have become larger in
size
so here all of flex items are occupying
the nta space
that they can fit into the container in
other words
they're occupying the maximum space
available inside the container
they can visualize this better if they
again comment the margin property
you can see they're touching each other
now and occupying all the space that
they can
that's about the flex group property let
me uncover this margin property now
so even if you change this 100
they're not going to get any bigger than
this that's because
the value only matters in relation to
the rest
let's reset this value to 1 and try to
understand how the value matters
in relation with the other flex grow
values
let's set a flex score property to item
4 and
give a 3.
so here item number four is three times
bigger than the rest of the flex
items by this i'm sure you can
understand how the flex group property
works relatively
when i change this three to five it's
going to become five times bigger than
the other flex items that's all about
the flex group property
let's remove the flex screw property
from item number four
and discuss about a short end property
so
the last three properties we are
learning have a shortened property to
them
we can directly call them using the flex
keyword
so with the flex keyword we can declare
three different values
the first value will be for a flex grow
property
the second will be for flex shrink and
the last will be for flex basis
when we simply give only the first value
it will automatically understand that
we're declaring the flex grow value
so if we remove the grow keyword from
here
every flex item is still occupying the
maximum space
this method is going to be extremely
handy when it comes to real world
projects
and in most cases we'll be using the
shortened property in our project
maybe we want one of our flex items to
grow larger than the rest
for example let's try growing a last
item
now setting flex 5 to item number 5
you can see that it is occupying the
maximum space
and the rest are relatively occupying
the available space
this is all about the flex curve
property
next up we're going to see the flex
basis property
flex basis property will set the width
of a flex item
instead of using the width property we
can use the flex basis
using the flex basis property or the
width property would mean the same
that's always a personal choice but in
my opinion
i would say it is always good to
practice to use the flex basis property
so that we'll be able to differentiate
the flex item and the normal item
now for our example i'm going to change
this to flex basis
and set this to 75 percentage
when we're using the flex basis property
we should declare
a percentage based value or a
pixel-based value
now the item number 5 is occupying 75
percentage of the container
and the rest are altered to occupy the
remaining 25 percentage space
by setting the flex bases to auto in the
background
do not worry if you're not able to
understand the difference between these
properties
we're going to use them a lot in our
course so you'll eventually understand
them
out of practice the very last property
we're going to see in this video
is flex shrink so to show you guys what
the flexuring property does
let me change this percentage value to a
pixel based value
maybe let me change this to 700 pixels
right let me also minimize my browser
window to demonstrate this property
now if i decrease the viewports with
just see what happens
so you can see that our item number five
shrinks at a certain break point
in spite of setting its flex basis to
700 pixels
it shrinks at a certain point to avoid
this
we declare the flex string property and
set it to zero
the only two values to the flexoring
property 1
and 0. so it works as a binary property
by default it is set of 1 which means it
will shrink the flex item at a point
let's now try setting the flexuring
property to zero and see what happens
but before that let me expand my browser
window size
going to my text editor i'm going to set
a flexuring property to item number five
and set it to zero
now if i try to decrease my browser
window size
well you can see that after setting
flexuring to 0
no matter how much size we take off from
the viewport the item number 5
is not shrinking but the rest of the
items are
overflowing the viewport in most case
people ignore to understand that they're
using the flexuring property
in real time we use the flex keyword
where we can consecutively declare all
three properties
flex grow flex shrink and the flex basis
where we only target the flex basis aka
the width property to set the flex
items with and that's how
we'll be implementing in our course too
after watching this video
i highly encourage everyone to open up
the cheat sheets
and practice until this point in the
next video
we're going to learn the rest of the
flex container properties and
in this section
before we end the section i would like
to teach you guys how to handle
a lot of flex items into the flex
container
so right now we have five flex items
let's simply add another five flex items
to our container
and reset their class names
so you can see that all these flex items
are closely packed
to fit into the container and some are
overflowing the flex container
i've zoomed my browser to 150 percentage
for the demonstration purpose
if you don't find these items
overflowing simply zoom your browser
window as i've did
now coming back to the point we have
this one last video for this section
because we've got a solution if you find
our flex items getting cramped up like
this
so we can use the flexwrap property to
overcome this issue
the default value for flex wrap is no
wrap
and that's why our flex items are
overflowing the container
but if we create a flex prep property
inside the container selector
and set it a wrap
then this will create a new line like
this to fit all the flex items inside
the container
if in case we are a selector for item
number 10
and set the flex to 1
you can see item number 10 is occupying
its maximum space
in the line now if you're showing the
browser size
then the flexwrap property will wrap the
flex items more and more
to ensure that all the flex items fit
into the container
and once again this is going to be
extremely useful for the responsive
design
when we have less amount of space in the
screen
now let me increase the height of the
container here and show you guys what
will happen
maybe let's set this to 600 pixels and
see what happens
see here we still have two rows but why
do we have this empty space in between
that's because of the align content
property which we haven't discussed yet
that's again a flex container property
so let's create a align content property
into the container selector
and set it a flex start
now as you can see every row in our flex
container is at the top of the container
therefore the align content property
aligns the row and the cross axis into
the container
again we can use the same values for the
align content property
as we use for the align items and the
align soft property
here i want you guys to pause the video
and
analyze the difference between the align
items align self
and the align content properties
now let's set the align content to
center
so as you can see our rows are aligned
at the center of the container
we can also change the flex end
and yes the rows are at the end of the
container
then let's see the space around
space between
and finally the space evenly
so they all work in the same logic as
you see
these properties will take some time for
you to memorize
but you don't have to really worry about
it because from now on
you're only going to use the flexbox in
our main project
kudos to everyone we've mastered the
concept of flexbox
let's not waste any more time we've got
a beautiful app to be constructed inside
our website
so i'll meet you guys in the next
section where we'll be reconstructing a
navbar
and the hero section and then we'll move
on to our app